foreign
Vanessa is with us in Richmond Virginia
hi Vanessa welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave I'm such a fan they asked me to
talk quick so but I just want to say hi
and thank you for taking my call thank
you how can we help
yes I have a question about Ross Roth
away currently
I have a
Road that's in a very high fee
oh that my husband left me I think about
eight years and I want to be move it to
a Index Fund
that is low cost low maintenance
um and that's what I want to do and I
want to ask you when should I do that
now that the market is
low or do I wait a couple of years it
doesn't matter and do it whenever it
doesn't
um I I want you to be sure what you're
doing you need to sit down maybe with
one of our Smart Vista pros and have
them discuss this with you and teach you
about it because you've been reading
something about fee mutual funds are
evil and no load mutual funds means no
fees and that's not true no load mutual
funds have fees too including index
funds they're annual maintenance fees
and the annual maintenance fees are
higher on those typically than they are
on commissioned funds and sometimes so
much so that they make you wish you'd
pay the commission mathematically
so uh that may not be true with yours I
don't know I own some of each I have
some index funds and I have some mutual
funds that are not index funds that have
uh that have a commission charge to them
uh you can set the commission charges up
to be what are called a shares which is
generally what I do up front you pay
your commission or you can do managed
funds which is where the uh the broker
that helps you with this like a
smartvester pro would charge like one
percent a year and you can have any
mutual fund you want inside of there
then and the fees the fees are done away
with then other than the maintenance
fees the maintenance fees are always
there on all funds
well it was over a million now it's it's
the 850k yeah and so that's not
beautiful
huh I did not do the fees of course the
market if it was for if it was a million
in January an index fund would be 850
right now
oh okay the Market's down
every million is turned into 850 this
year so far it'll come back but that's
not due to it being a bad fund
necessarily uh if it was down to 600 I
might be wondering what the Flip's going
on but um it sounds like you're
paralleling the market about anyway
um I mean just look up and see what the
S P 500 is down since January 1. you can
Google it I I don't know it off the top
of my head but it's right around 15 to
16 something like that and so and that
would put you at 8 50. 15 off of
millions 150. so
um you know that puts you there I I
would sit down and you know study what
it is that you're trying to do and make
sure you're actually doing it meaning
are you getting away from the fees after
all that you think you are or are you
gaining stability that you think you're
gaining by going to an index fund uh
because some of these articles on that
are out there make it sound like index
funds fix the whole world and they don't
fix the whole world there's still Index
Fund S P 500 fund follows the market
exactly it is the market
and so if the Market's down 15 you're
gonna be down 15 and if you're in a
mutual fund that outperforms the market
a little bit you might be down 14 which
my portfolio is primarily non-index
funds and it's not down as much as the
market is and it's generally when the
market is up it's generally up more than
the market is so it outperforms the
market meaning it beats the s p uh and I
don't pay a huge bunch of extra fees
that offset that for it you know what
what helped me in a situation like this
because it sounds like this is she's
trying to make this a math problem but
it sounds like she's watched 150 000
evaporate yeah and when our body gets
stressed we've all heard this fight or
flight those are action oriented
responses I gotta go do something I got
to start swinging at something I gotta
get out of here
and the real uh discipline here is just
still and that's hard because our bodies
are designed to
go do a thing and I Gotta Move It from
here I gotta move it over here and here
over here just be still be still and
that's hard to do yeah sure and I were
hiking in Montana and they've got all
these bear signs up everywhere and
you're supposed to carry bear spray or
something stronger
which is what I would prefer and all
this stuff and so we're walking up
through there and then there's this long
this like epistle uh on a sign of what
to do if a bear comes and I didn't
honestly didn't know this I've been out
in the woods all my life but um
apparently stand very still yeah which
is really counterintuitive if there's a
big freaking bear in front of you by the
way it is a bear Market we're talking
about so standing real still uh the
metaphor works here pretty good but uh
or if you and I are hiking the whole
thing yeah who can outrun I don't have
to outrun the bear I just got outrun I
got outrun Dave that's it that's it yeah
one guy sits down starts putting on his
tennis shoes what are you doing I don't
have to outrun the bear I just you can
outrun that bear you're right I gotta
outrun you that's right but yeah just be
still be still and that's so hard man
it's so hard yeah it's um just how we're
wired but I I think that's but don't be
still out of ignorance uh either go
ahead go ahead out of awareness go ahead
and sit down and learn what is the
proper technique
in the middle of this kind of world that
we're in today and the proper technique
in general is just stay invested but if
you're moving from one mutual fund to
another mutual fund they're both down
that's a net zero you know deal so
you're going from one that sucks to a
you know down 15 to another one that's
down 15 you like it better that's that's
a net zero you're not you're not really
losing anything on that pulling your
money out of the market while it's down
you're pretty much locking in and
guaranteeing that you're gonna lose your
butt that's right you lost 150 because
it's going to jump back up maybe next
year or maybe shortly after that I don't
know uh whenever Biden gets through
screwing around with this stuff or
whoever it is the dadgum Fed or whoever
else is monkeying around with this deal
but as soon as it starts moving again it
takes off and again because it always
does then you're going to be standing
there 150 000 poorer right so you don't
want to jump out stay out it's timing
the market it'll get you killed but in
this case yeah I would I would stick
with it so um you get some advice learn
about it think about what you're doing